and there's been a lot of talk about
who's to blame for the end in new
england now i think that the
more important world events have caused
people to be less obsessed with laying
blame about brady leaving than they
would have been but from your
perspective is there someone to blame i
mean i look at it and i say what can you
want patriots fans more than 20 years
and six super bowls with one guy it
ain't gonna last forever he's playing
three years max anyway and who knows
what kind of skills he has now in
comparison to what they were but if
somebody is upset who should they be
blaming chris well and to me you're
right i mean first off it was it's been
the greatest showing we've ever seen
between quarterback and head coach so
let's all just appreciate that before we
start blaming you know one guy or the
other and i understand that's the
business we're in you know i think okay
if you're gonna make me blame one guy
i'd probably put a little more blame on
bill belichick but i don't necessarily
sit here and go all of it goes on him i
would go like 52 belichick 48 brady i
think brady deserves some of this as
well you know i think brady
unrealistically is asking for you know
respect and wants to enjoy his job and
that's just not in the dna of a guy like
bill belichick he's always the general
it doesn't matter how many super bowls
you've won he's always looking for the
next one so he's always coaching like
that so i think brady some some has
gotten a little made i don't want to say
disrespectful be sensitive towards that
to the end of his career and then of
course we know belichick makes hard-line
decisions to run that business and
that's where he he deserves you know
some of the blame for this split as well
yeah i think bill belichick ultimately
didn't want tom brady back and was ready
to rip off the band-aid and move on and
i think the offers that were made or
weren't made to tom brady from last
august until now i think that he got the
idea that bill was ready to move forward
and look from brady's perspective 20
years of belichick is all he could take
and if that's the one flaw in the
patriot way that you can't expect
someone to endure into a third decade of
dealing with bill belichick then so be
it right i mean you get a guy who gets
to the point where i can do 20 years i
can't do 21 with this guy okay we can
live with that
right i mean you know you can't have it
all it's it's been an amazing run it's
not always easy i mean hey we've we've
heard of this before i mean i don't
think joe montana and bill walsh were
like holding hands on their way to the
practice field every day you know you've
heard about magic johnson and pat riley
back in the day like i think magic
johnson was like oh pat riley's leaving
l.a thank god i mean these practices and
the way he runs things they're brutal so
this is part of you know successful
relationships in sports
and yeah i i think more or not i think
the sense we've gotten is that belichick
and his coaching staff did want to move
on you know if they were stuck with
brady one more year or didn't do it i
don't think it would have been the end
of the world but i think they were ready
for a next phase there in new england
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports